I think judge of course my dear this
year's midterms are shaping up to be the
most expensive and history why some of
it's because of rich donors like this
one this is Marcy and she's a
billionaire with a cause let's say she
wants more bike lanes everywhere and
she's ready to spend five million
dollars to support politicians who agree
with her
Marcy has a lot of options for how to
spend that money we are going to help
her understand them her first option is
the simplest she could give money
directly to a candidate who supports
bike lanes that contribution is limited
to two thousand seven hundred dollars
per election or double that if the
candidate runs in the primary and
general election for Marcy this
contribution is just the tip of the
iceberg Marcy's second option is
leadership PACs many Congress people
think Paul Ryan Nancy Pelosi have
established leadership PACs these are
pools of money that operate outside of a
candidate's campaign when leadership
PACs were approved in the late 70s the
idea was that Congress people could use
the funds to network and gain favor but
the lines have blurred and now that
money is typically used for travel and
things that quote raise a politician's
profile Marcy can give $5,000 per year
to each leadership PAC for candidates
that support bike lanes
let's say there are 10 such candidates
that's $50,000 but Marcin wants to give
a lot more than that so next she picks
the party that supports bike lanes and
gives money to each of their National
Party accounts these accounts can't give
money directly to candidates but they
can coordinate with them on how the
money is spent each party has three the
overall national committee the one
focused on the house and the one on the
Senate but that's not all in December
2014 Congress passed a bill allowing
more money to come in through three
add-on accounts headquarters election
recounts and conventions Marcy can give
this much per year to each of these
accounts and this much to each of these
over a two-year cycle that it's up to
over two million dollars that's more
like it
the Marcy still has a lot of money left
to give so she's taking a look at super
PACs this is where things get wild
donors like Marcy as well as
corporations and unions have no limit
the amount of money they can give to
super PACs that support a candidate this
option was introduced in 2010 with
federal and Supreme Court rulings such
as citizens united and a series of
advisory opinions by the Federal
Election Commission and ever since a
huge bulk of political donations now run
through PACs with names like progress
tomorrow and principals project so
what's the big deal
super PACs are not supposed to donate
directly to candidates or even
coordinate on spending but each cycle
candidates and super PACs pushed the red
line a little further out even with all
these benefits Marcy's not going to give
money to a super PAC
that's because donating millions to a
super PAC is public record and Marcy's
feeling a little shy about her last few
million which leads us to Marcy's final
option donating to a non-profit
Marcy's giving the rest of her five
million dollars to bike lanes for
America I've made up non-profit that
allows her to donate unlimited money to
influence her cause and keep her
identity secret in turn bike lanes for
America can use Marcy's money to try and
influence elections usually through
attack ads the catch is that these
groups must spend at least 50% on
something other than politics but these
numbers aren't heavily monitored and
skeptics question whether some
nonprofits are following this rule so
now that Marcy's spent all of her money
what's next
and what's next is that all these
different organizations figure out how
to spend the money
Marcy gave them and for everybody who's
not a Marcy we just get to see more of
this